yeah um t4e to be cautious its rivers
yeah i'm not sure why is called Reapers
let's look at this does he have a text
them now no yeah we was can refer to all
kinds of things this sort of fun did
called a puzzle or riddle or something
it could also refer to them yeah the
main person in Nam and the rebus novels
written by Ian Rankin very nice mystery
novels if you like this hmm what I'm a
bit stir a bit surprised nitey for out
of the blue and yeah probably you know
me I'm a very very simple minded person
I want to spawn efore ng7 a double
attack yeah if you want some really good
detective story so I think the maybe the
correct Thomas is that the police
procedural hard to pronounce for me at
least it's it's good stuff if you like
those crime novels in Rankin's serious
with inspector rebus must be like more
than a dozen books he actually retired
him and one of the a couple of years ago
and now I saw that there's a new bug
book with him being the main character
again as somehow expected that okay but
back to the game he's just looking at
this this double attack and asking
himself
what am i doing now there's really no
way to to keep the material I think yeah
you need to give up on and in some way
yeah this is one of them okay I can
cannot really not take it with after all
those Queen moves okay yeah he's
probably threatening to take on g2 maybe
even with the rook what I want to try us
I know it looks terribly slow as f3e for
Bishop g5 this is what term would help
okay I is some aiming for long castles
maybe maybe i should add one point move
my stuff develop pieces i came yeah this
is not not completely clear this
position some but the Queen on h4 is not
badly placed I need to I need to make
sure to develop the rest of my pieces
the problem they cannot so easily attack
the Queen oh he can I cannot I briefly
thought Queen f8 and something but ok
it's not a big deal have a bishop only
three but it's not so easy now to him to
to find a way forward
look you one or something there's not a
lot to replan what you want it's not
time maybe okay let's try this I don't
really want the King on g1 this looks
bad I try look everyone f2f1 bishop f1
f1 f2 the rock and Bishop to everyone
this actually would even allow me to to
move the light yet somehow this is some
this is probably am some compensation
maybe this compensation I don't know I'm
wondering about night h5 this is a good
idea getting rid of one powerful nights
are interesting is please play on this
on this weakness maybe should get the
rook out of the long diagonal d5 he
could have probably taken and go on on
the sea three Pawn md5 I don't really
want to do that t5 it seems like giving
him additional ideas
I can't move the night now I'm not quite
sure well night f form this move but
this car truck look to h6 and I don't
want that maybe this is rotated too many
away d 5 I would actually I can leave
this thing on now maybe I can oh this is
so this is good news this is really good
news I can okay I now have f5 for the
night and then stuff like h3g three
bishop age three and so on yeah this is
killed both they're both this nights
this is why I like this move for me
I could even play g4 why not actually
just keep this big space advantage and
get the Queen off of this later
so I can basically just stay put on the
Kings side and trying to to do something
on the other side yeah but I can I can
advance IAM wire why not just know push
push the edge born yeah just push the
edge part but h5 is not a stable square
really i thought yeah okay i can i can
just take it i think because this is
such a big threat g6 or age six and
bishop and 36 problem okay is attacking
a form yeah but is just a pawn right can
we can detect his look
good defense time morning no I can take
it out check black yeah yeah some more
yet say play from the porn but some i
can't i have difficult difficult I mean
it was it was basically over after he
went fyf before that i'm i'm not i'm not
one hundred percent sure if there's
something yeah the computer just says
white wins by but by huge huge margin
like okay black is completely done i am
a not so sure it's still some practical
chances but what I think was was good in
fact as this rook f1 move look f1 f2
Bishop f1 this was a good maneuver to
make em those this is night for example
mobile that it can actually move it
otherwise hear you've been tied down and
of course this is the screen is really
nice it's not attackable in any way it's
really a really nice yeah he just played
this is this too early need to play what
the note we should be seven or something
first yeah thanks for watching